in der korona krise stark die zahl der
psychischen erkrankungen deutlich an
20 prozent der krankmeldungen sind
bereits darauf zurückzuführen so eine
umfrage der techniker-krankenkasse
stehen wir jetzt vor einem corona
burnout laut einer umfrage der uni
erfurt haben fast 45 prozent angst und
über 58 prozent halten das corona virus
für besorgniserregend depressive
symptome treten bis zu fünf mal häufiger
auf als vor der pandemie gerade junge
menschen zwischen 18 und 25 jahren
leiden besonders unter der einschränkung
von kontaktmöglichkeiten langzeitschäden
der generation carola nicht
ausgeschlossen weil der begriff 2020
corona burnout wie ist das damals gerade
jetzt schon ein bisschen gesehen dass
gerade die jungen menschen ganz
besonders leiden stimmt das und wenn ja
warum ist das so es hat viel mit den
sozialen kontakten zu tun die so
eingeschränkt sind im moment also das
ist im grunde auch für die diesen
anstieg der depressiven symptome ja je
einsamer oder je zurückgezogene menschen
sein müssen also waren sie vorher
teilweise auch schon aber jetzt eben
auch noch erzwungenermaßen desto mehr
fördert das depressive symptome und auch
alle möglichen anderen
krankheitssymptome und angst also
einsamkeit ist löst starken schmerz aus
das ist parallel eigentlich zu der
angstreaktion angst ist ein warnsignal
und einsamkeit gefühl genau so nämlich
das signal ist was wir aus unserer
entwicklungsgeschichte haben wieder
zurück in die gruppe nimmt wieder
kontakte auf sonst stirbt store in der
savanne
ja ja und das haben wir immer noch und
jetzt kann es so zu sagen also es läuft
ins leere
und dann reagieren viele menschen mit
depressionen oder angst symptome
schlafstörungen sind auch ungefähr
verfünffacht hat seine beginn der
kontakt beschränkungen und dann sind
alle möglichen folge symptome auch daran
und und die jugendlichen die hier leiden
darunter mehr weil sie es nicht erklären
können oder warum warum brechen sie dann
aus was ist da der hintergrund dabei bei
jugendlichen
die entwicklungsaufgabe in dem alter
haben sich aus dem elternhaus zu lösen
und eine unabhängige in den täter
aufzubauen und das tun sie mit
gleichaltrigen und das ist jetzt
plötzlich dermaßen abgrund gefahren
nicht in die schule gehen zu können ist
aus diesem grund schon wirklich schlimm
gewesen für viele jugendliche erst mal
so die auch toll keine schule und dann
haben sie gemerkt da treffe ich ja meine
gleichaltrigen nicht mehr jeden tag so
wie vorher
und dieses auch feiern partys machen was
ja jetzt sehr viel kritisiert wird das
ist ein sozialtraining für jugendliche
und das ist auch nicht immer nur einfach
freude auf einer party zu sein ja die
üben und trainieren und sie müssen sich
überwinden und sind schüchtern und
unsicher und dann geben sie trotzdem in
kontakt und dann geheimdiensten training
im endeffekt ja es ist genau das ist der
entwicklungsschritte einfach dazu gehört
das ist ein ja könnte man sagen auch ein
inneres motiv das will wollen die
einfach in dem alter
da gab es ja auch eine große diskussion
in den sozialen medien darüber ob
sozusagen auch der zustand dass
jugendliche nicht feiern dürfen und dass
eben auch offen benennen
ob das so ein first world problem ist
und da glaube ich gibt es auch immer
zwei meinungen also das mag am anfang so
erscheinen
aber trotzdem ist es so dass natürlich
eine menge wegbricht in dem moment
genauso wie sie es ja letztlich auch
beschrieben haben
mit mit glaube ich auch verheerenden
folgen auch was soll das eigene befinden
angeht und das merke ich auch in meinem
umfeld ob jetzt auch bei meinen nichten
oder ich bin mit hat eine freundin die
psychologin ist und die eben auch gesagt
hat dass auch was das thema psychische
erkrankungen immer noch sehr tabuisiert
was die einweisung angeht und so weiter
das ist alles viel akuter geworden und
auch in berlin und in brandenburg ist es
schon zu fällen gekommen dass leute
wirklich woanders hin gefahren werden
müssen und das ist wirklich sehr akut
und sehr konkret was sagen wir dann
machen ich meine jetzt als eltern zum
beispiel was soll ich meine jetzt meine
kinder sind jetzt nicht so im fire modus
mit 7 und 4 auf jeden fall nicht diese
richtung aber nichtsdestotrotz was
sollen eltern jetzt machen generell es
da draußen die uns auch zu schauen viele
mütter schauen uns zu wir können jetzt
auch nicht anders sagen ja comeback ist
es egal komm mach dein ding oder wie
geht man mit sowas um
also regeln sind ja auch gut unter
sollen sich die jugendlichen auch daran
halten
aber man kann es als eltern fördern
indem man zum beispiel sagt loskommen
jetzt telefonieren und gehe mit einem
mit deiner freundin oder mit deinem
besten kumpel gehe mit dem raus in parka
und macht sport also ich kenne mein sohn
des 17
ich kenne viele jugendliche die viel
mehr sport machen im moment und die
gehen alle raus die machen das draußen
wie verabreden sich zum joggen vorher
nicht gemacht
mir fällt es immer ein bisschen schwer
auch wenn sie gerade viele erklärungen
dafür geliefert haben das fire volk also
ich sage mal es würden jugendliche bis
anfang 20 da ist man also im zentrum vom
feiern so unfassbar viel mitleid für die
zu finden weil ich finde dass ist schon
es ging so viel es gibt so viel gefahr
von so etwas aus und ich es auch super
schwer nachzuvollziehenden tieferen sinn
es haben so ein bisschen als
sozialisierung beschrieben aber im
endeffekt sehr viel grün grüner rey und
ein bisschen was trinken und spaß haben
und das risiko dass dort eben besteht
ist so wahnsinnig viel hörig war
gleichzeitig aber auch ich bin schon
auch werden von das wort corona burnout
irgendwie ich bin emotional zwischen
kommen wir packen das alles müssen wir
pragmatisch angehen bis hin zu ich kann
nicht mehr vor uns liegen jetzt
irgendwie die nächsten sechs sieben
dunklen monate wie soll man es machen
also wie sollen wir das schaffen was
macht man denn wenn man diese momente
der hoffnungslosigkeit hat diese momente
der unsicherheit wir können ja auch
nichts planen werden wir keine
highlights ich meine weihnachten ja das
wird das nächste highlight was uns allen
bevorsteht es neuer vergessen wie gehen
wir beginnen
so war es um genau das ist zum beispiel
auch ganz wichtig wie erklären wir wie
gehen wir mit der familie mit dem paar
bei den kindern um in dieser doch im
freiwilligen lockdown wie es so schön
umschrieben wird immer mehr also eine
sache die man machen kann ist dass man
überlegt zum beispiel bei weihnachten
was ist denn das schöne darin ja so dass
weihnachten ist so der aus rahmen man
trifft familie freunde und so weiter was
ist das schöne gefühl darin
und das ist dieses gemeinschaftliche
oder
in seiner friedlichen stimmung
zusammenkommen und dann kann man
überlegen wie kann man diese stimmung
dieses gefühl lösen von den äußeren
rahmen der dann eben nicht geht dass bei
jugendlichen übrigens das gleiche
gaddafi hat keine großen feiern machen
aber vielleicht können sie ein
gemeinschaftsgefühl auch zu dritt oder
zu viert erreichen und mit weihnachten
kann man dann überlegen machen wir es
über ein video meeting oder machen wir
einen spaziergang draußen also gehen wir
raus oder finden wir eine andere form
dafür so dass das gefühl und dieses ja
was eben für jeden dann auch ein
bisschen anders ist was weihnachten zum
beispiel bedeutet das dass erhalten
bleiben kann das ist natürlich auch ganz
eng gekoppelt an die sozialisation an
die persönlichkeit zwar nicht mal und
das was sie beschreiben setzt ja auch
sehr viel selbstreflexion voraus und ich
merke dass es ganz viele junge menschen
gibt in meinem umfeld aber auch bei mir
ganz persönlich also weihnachten ist ja
auch deswegen highlight aufgrund der
ganzen vorfreude und das was uns spaß
macht sind da natürlich nicht die video
konferenzen sondern das ist ein
weihnachtsmarkt glühwein trinken ist es
in die heimat fahren das ist bei
einander sein
das ist die vorfreude also ich finde
dass niemand vor freude und hoffnung
gegeben
nicht so wichtig ist muss es mal gegeben
worauf wir uns freuen können immer im
leben ja das ist das sowieso ganz ganz
trinkst und traurig und ich finde da
passiert in der tat auch psychologisch
gerade was wir sind und waren alle sehr
sehr geduldig und wir werden das auch
weiterhin sein und jetzt ist natürlich
auch vorbild charakter gefragt aber mir
geht es genauso wie der patrizier dass
sich auch merkel dass ich manchmal so
ein bisschen ankämpfen muss ich will
nicht sagen lähmungserscheinungen
weildorf hatten haben wir das privileg
das wird zu viel zu tun haben
aber ich kann sehr viele menschen da
draußen verstehen die gerade auch liegen
bleiben und sie haben nicht vergessen
der in der erste lockdown der war im
frühling die sonne ging auf die blumen
gegen auf man hat so ein bisschen leben
gespürt jetzt nehmen wir mal auf die
düstere jahreszeit zu das ist jetzt
nicht unbedingt so dass man sagt johanna
das ist ja mal erfrischend ihr alles
also das kann schon schwierig werden und
ich glaube viele das thema hatten wir
auch auf die viele hatten auch probleme
in der familie mann ist einfach mal auf
deutsch gesagt auf dem sack gegangen bei
diesem doktor das hat einfach wahnsinnig
genervt und keiner muss mehr so richtig
wo seine position ist wie sieht es da
aus was was können sie dafür tipps geben
dass gerade das die beziehung eltern
kinder partnerschaft eine therapie kann
das einigermaßen heil überstehen ist
eine riesige herausforderung für alle
kinder und das positive daran ist
wir können uns neu kennenlernen also
partner partnerin aber auch als ganze
familie
und es erfordert so viel reden immer
wieder neu verhandeln
wie machen wir es brauchst du zeit für
dich alleine was machen die anderen dann
geben die ins andere zimmer gehen die
raus also wie verteilt man das so dass
jeder auch mal zeit für sich hat was
alle eigentlich auch brauchen
das ist das eine und das andere was man
machen kann zum beispiel für paare
ich empfehle tatsächlich eine tägliche
fünf minuten 27 minuten das reicht genau
was man wissen muss sich so lange sein
aber ein wettstreit oder ohne scheu
unternehmens wichtig ohne streit und
wirklich sich fünf minuten
zusammensetzen absoluter fokus auf die
anderen personen und nicht nicht so der
austausch und schon gar nicht über orga
und alltags kram und stress sondern
wirklich fragen und zu hören also wie
geht es dir wirklich und dann auch zu
hören also weniger ein gesprächen wird
es gleich eine diskussion und dann aber
du hast auch nicht sondern wirklich
einfach nur hören wie geht es dem
anderen mit einem interesse darauf und
haben alleine schon fünf minuten rede
anteil ich glaube weil mir zuhause
müsste man das machen wir beim duell
zwischen job und beiden mit einem
youtube
dann wäre es vielleicht zehn oder 15
minuten und muss es auch nicht täglich
sein ich bin nicht so für so strenge
regeln aber überhaupt zu wissen dass es
eine zeit gibt wo man ein mal innehält
und wirklich konzentriert es auf den
anderen und mit kindern natürlich
genauso das kann man werden genauso dann
umsatz apropos kinder und jugendliche
bleibt denn die gehen die korona
generation sozusagen auf der strecke
sie hatten mal was von narbenbildungen
et cetera geschrieben
sich dafür ausgesprochen ein bisschen
davon genau das ist so ein begriff
narbenbildung also etwas was in der
eigenen lebensgeschichte hinterlassen
bleibt und dann auch nicht so weg geht
und man spricht jetzt immer mehr in der
entwicklungsforschung bei jugendlichen
das man vermutet dass so eine
narbenbildung sich entwickelt also das
heißt in einer phase wo jugendliche aber
auch andere lebensphasen wo man gerade
expansiv rausgeht da wird man runter
gedeckelt so zu sagen und das ist eine
erfahrung die sich auch festsetzen aber
nach mit narben sind sie weiter sind ja
nicht negativ also das wird ja oft auch
defizitär betrachtet aber wichtig ist ja
was wir mit namen machen und menschen
die aus schwierigen verhältnissen kommen
die tragen auch narben mit sich und ich
glaube es geht darum ich komme wieder
zum thema verwundbarkeit mit diesen
namen auch zu arbeiten und wenn das
heißt dass man dann empfindsamer bild
mitfühlender dass sie all die jahre
selbstverständlich geglaubten freiheiten
dass die eben nicht selbstverständlich
sind ich weiß nicht wie es euch geht ich
finde schon erstes lernen wir uns selber
neu kennen unsere umwelt menschen neu
kennen und ich sage ja immer krise macht
ehrlich und auch die waren tiefen
wünsche werden ja ganz anders offenbart
gerade also ich bin sozusagen dagegen
immer so zu tun als wenn krise chance
wäre
aber trotzdem glaube ich kann es helfen
der umgang damit also auch mit mit
diesen abend bei unseren kindern also
werden dass narben seien im sinne von
die werden hoffnungsloser blicken
hoffnungsloser in die zukunft was kann
da passieren was macht diese zeit mit
unseren kindern was sind das für ein
abend das kann sein dass eben durch
diese erfahrung ich kann ich werde
ständig ausgebremst ich kann nicht
machen was ich eigentlich machen will
das kann zu sowas führen aber ich teile
das absolut was sie sagen also es geht
darum dass man auch aus schwierigen
erfahrungen lernt ja also was kann man
daraus lernen zb was wir alle lernen im
moment ist ganz toll mit unsicherheit
umzugehen was glaube ich in deutschland
nicht so unsere stärke ist wo alles auf
die minute geplante ist da haben andere
länder vielleicht ein vorteil wenn es
auf stunden dann doch nicht so
dann kommt zum beispiel mit der
pünktlichkeit und wir können lernen
flexibler zu sein und mit enttäuschungen
auch anders umzugehen also wir also man
hört ja immer so auch du kannst alles
schaffen wenn du es nur wirklich willst
ja und im moment ist es so die äußeren
bedingungen sind so dass man einfach
sehr wenig einfluss nehmen kann als
einzelne person auf das große und dann
kann man das in seinem alltag versuchen
zu integrieren aber wir sehen
schließlich man das runter dann auf den
alten alltag wie kann ich meinem umfeld
nicht nur den kindi kinder sondern
meinen hinweg so ein bisschen motivation
geben so ein schub geben aber man hört
ja aus jeder ärgert dass überstehe ich
jetzt nicht noch in locktow und so
weiter und so fort wie kann man so ein
bisschen was hilft frischen haff
tierische logi einbringen
die frau soll mit einem grün anzug in
frische luft viel verabreden also nicht
einfach was so kommt sondern dreimal am
tag mit verschiedenen leuten zum
telefonieren verabreden zum beispiel und
eine feste mittagspause ein plan wo man
sonst vielleicht gesagt hat auch mache
ich irgendwann und dann hat man in dem
alltag schon mal mehr struktur werden
außenrum sich alles so ein bisschen
auflöst also als ersatz sozusagen im
kleinen eben eigenen alltag wo wir etwas
beeinflussen können eines healthcare
zeit am abend finde ich immer sehr schön
so was haben sie auch ein buch dazu
geschrieben war stehen bestimmt auch
tolle tipps drin ja genau da geht es
auch um die verkehr zeit also eine kurze
kleine 10 15 minuten reicht die zeit
nehmen die nur für mich selber ist und
manche schreiben da also ich bin ja
immer sehr für schreiben aber das mögen
auch was alle räumen oder in höhen die
nafta journal kann man führen
dankbarkeit das mache ich zum beispiel
seit corona mache ich fast meistens
sogar zweimal täglich dass ich
aufschreibe für dinge für die ich
dankbar bin an dem tag oder an dem was
noch kommt und das mag so ein bisschen
banal auch klingen aber es hilft dabei
dass man sagt ich konnte auch was lernen
also wo ist das gute im schwierigen
jetzt geht es aber natürlich auch vielen
menschen so da müssen wir uns ja auch
ganz ehrlich in die augen schauen so
geht es uns wahrscheinlich allen die
hier sitzen nicht
aber es gibt den menschen ganz konkrete
ängste also da geht es um job da geht es
um die existenz da geht es um wirkliche
einsamkeit ich denk an alte menschen die
sich wirklich nicht mehr raus trauen
ich denke an menschen bei denen es
wirtschaftlich an die existenz geht es
ist ja mit so vielen ängsten verbunden
den wird ja alleine nicht helfen sich
auf zu schreiben
für was sie dankbar sind wir können die
mit ihren ängsten umgehen die sie ja
wahrscheinlich noch monate lang
begleiten werden
also das ist auch etwas was wir lernen
können nämlich mit schwierigen emotionen
die die überhaupt die irgendwie zu
bewältigen
das lernen wir nicht in der schule nicht
im elternhaus oft auch nicht
und der weg ist also viele verdrängen
ihre schwierigen gefühle angst wut
trauer schmerz enttäuschung frust der
bessere weg ist wenn man sie anerkennt
sie dürfen da sein und wenn man hindurch
geht also das heißt diese gefühle
durchlebt die halten nie lange also
waren laune fühlen genau dass man die
möglich spürt also meine wenn man
richtig wütend ist lieber ein mal
schreien dieses misst corona ich kann
nicht mehr wie soll das weitergehen oder
genau ruhig auch immer nach außen also
sozial verträglich würde ich immer sagen
es geht nicht darum alles aus zu agieren
und jetzt den bayern so gut bei den
mitmenschen abzulassen
darum geht es überhaupt nicht aber die
gefühle zu spüren
und die halten nicht lange gefühle
frauen immer nach einer weile wieder ab
und dann kann man dadurch gehen und
kommt anders wieder raus ja und da muss
man aufpassen nicht chronisch wird uns
in seine verbitterung führt oder in
sowas depressives aber man kann das auch
steuern und dann geht mal wieder raus
und dann ist man anders als vorher
woran merke ich denn wenn es irgendwie
in eine depression oder in einer
richtung angst geht die jetzt nicht mehr
zu einem normalen leben dazugehört also
da gibt es gibt bestimmte warnsignale
worauf ihr achten muss in sachen angst
in dieser zeit dass ich sage jetzt
glaube ich muss ich mir doch hilfe holen
die gedanken sind dann doch nicht mehr
so ganz normal normal ist wahrscheinlich
kein gott was ist psychologisch aber sie
wissen sie mein ja genau also wenn sich
gedanken immer wieder um dasselbe drehen
fast zwanghaft nah und starke
angstgefühle auch auslösen die merkmale
deutlich herzrasen und schweiß
diese typischen angstsymptome und wenn
das immer und immer wieder ist also wenn
es mal ist dann ist das kurzfristiger
stress der ist noch nichtmal ungesund
der der ungesunden stress ist der der
chronische wenn es immer und immer
wieder ist und dann sollte man sich
hilfe holen genauso wie wenn man über
längere zeit hinweg depressive symptome
bemerkt und die gehen ja also da ist
freudlosigkeit ein ganz wichtiges
anzeichen ja das weiß ich was es so
zusammen in sich hineinhören ist ganz
ganz wichtigen auch wirklich sensibel
dafür sein dass das auch in ordnung ist
nicht immer alles selbst managen zu
können
[Musik]